a guy that's uh trapped in the shittiest
basement i've seen in a while
you are a busy busy man you got a comedy
central
uh series uh it's a digital series and
it's called
robbie why don't you tell us a little
bit about robbie
so robbie is the main character
when you talk about it like this no one
gets interested the main character and
he likes basketball he likes coaching
it uh-huh so he's a basketball coach
he's a church league basketball coach
he's very uh delusional about his talent
and value
and he wants to take over his dad beau
bridges
he wants to take over his dad's job as
the high school
basketball coach and the series is
really about relationships and robbie
learning that maybe it's time to grow up
and also how do we do that if we're in
our 30s
i'm 40 now and i still don't know that
no i
i mean i made this sign and i'm only now
realizing
based on you seeing it that it's not
even adequate you said
look i lost some space here and i had to
do letter on num
words on top of words no no that is a
cry for help if ever i've seen one
you know i hear you describe
robbie as this deluded man child
uh living out his fantasies and it's
hard for me not to think
robbie rory do you know what i mean i
wrote from a very real place if that's
what you're
alluding to robbie's not so different
from me
robbie's not so different from america
you know what i mean
their show is about facing some hard
truths in order to grow in the right
direction and i believe that's kind of
where we're at you know what i mean
okay a little bit of vodka real quick i
didn't think i was going to get so deep
out of the game
vodka your other uh experiment donna
you have a pretty strong accent in the
show your character
now i know you're from the south yes um
and when i first met you i think the
first time you did stand up on my show
i swear to god i don't remember what
year that was i think it was 2012. i'm
i'm pretty good with years i'm pretty
sure it was 2012. you came on the show
as a stand-up you had a pretty strong
southern accent
i hate to um put you on the spot but
here's a clip of you in 2012 on my show
and um you sound like gomer pyle let's
take a look
it starts tonight we put a new occupy
movement together
we go down to lunchables and we yell at
the buildings y'all are the worst kind
of crackers
because that that's where they yell at
all the protests you know
explain that explain why your accent was
so okay no one's
no you don't know what the people at
home are doing
they're probably clapping right
i have a monitor here on everyone in
america no no
the ultimate zoom you're on the ultimate
zoom right i have a zoom of everyone in
america it shows 360 million little
faces and
no not one person clapping yeah
were you faking that accent that you're
putting a little english on the ball
i do that yeah yeah i it's fun to do
that because then it leaves people
uh guessing is this guy really southern
sometimes i do a german guy sometimes i
just do my own voice and then people
they don't know which one is which one
is which and honestly i get so deep into
these characters as a professional
actor as i'm often described and because
of that i
sometimes i stay in those spaces i i
really don't know what my real voice is
anymore either so
yeah well um and that could be a little
bit of the vodka also
yeah a little bit of the vodka and a
little bit of the looking away you don't
know
stop doing it you can't relate to people